je vais vous parler de campagne où
valenciennes associations et des bas
qu'on a appelée nissan alors qui est
pour la promotion de la culture de bd
colonna on m'a fait la magie tour
d'horizon dans mon voir un peu l'impact
qu'a plaidé pour l'abandon mais au monde
croit les chiffres
ensuite je vous parlais du produit avant
samedi le juste devant un bureau de
poste jusqu'à la vidéo dans le monde
vous obéissez à la lettre ce que je
disais
et ça marche je compte juste 1 3 et 1
fois contacté un de ses
vous savez ce qui s'est passé serait en
fait touché par ce qu'ils voient que par
son milieu c'est pour ça pour nous mais
c'est le mal est important que le
conseil sur un lob de malang mané lisier
à moi l'allemagne que le lot dire et
encore moins d'alpha visible à ce que ce
qu'on pense dans l'inconscient collectif
c'est que de bénévolat dans les pays du
tiers-monde
parce qu'ils en ont le plus besoin on
verra qu'au contraire c'est une
pratiquement life de développement plus
de pays développé plusieurs bénévoles
alors au québec 2007 le 2 5 millions
bénévoles soit 80% de la population qui
est plus de 15 ans a déjà payé d'action
les erreurs
l'équivalent de 2 595 millions 100 mille
rêves par an soit deux cent mille trois
cent soixante quatre emplois à la main
sur les richesses d'un milliard de
dollars uniquement pour aider aux états
unis en 2008 83 9 millions de bénévoles
15.5 milliarden données sans but
lucratif saublet de 230 milliards de
dollars en france le chiffre de 2010 12
millions de bénévoles sur 26
la fondation total 4 millions régulier
de double occasionnels qui consacre en
gagnant par semaine sauf le premier neuf
armes l'équivalent de 800 lundi dans ce
qui est mal en main c'est sauvage et du
golf français
le dot anticipation qui augmente avec le
niveau d'éducation et ça c'est un
chiffre important c'est la tradition
familiale sur le bénévolat dire qu'il
suffit comme un ou deux un des deux
parents j'ai été bénévole
le taux de participation pour 20% à 50%
à la mêlée politique d'éducation a
vraiment de la gueule 5% de la
population à les maintenir au mieux 5
millions de niveaux stables et richesses
créées la belgique 1,4 million de
maisons 241 emplois
le sens de 2009 137 millions d'euros
soit 10 500 documents créés par des
bénévoles a reconnu comme un homard
payer un agent
la seule chance au dinophysis c'est le
haut commissariat au plan pour une scène
et de l'union des réponses aux progrès
dans les quarante quatre mille
associations
de même il uniquement active soit 145
associations par cent mille habitants à
peu près le dixième de ce que connaît la
france seulement 200 300 66 association
tient la comptabilité sérieuse et 7% des
associations sont connectés à internet
dans des musées officiellement au moins
15 millions 288 147 d'adhésion
officielle
et puis une autre en 152 mille bénévoles
effectifs soit 96 millions d'heures
consacrées au bénévolat par année
l'équivalent de 50 6524 emplois
seulement par un second
l'âge moyen du bénévolat auprès de 40
uniquement 16% au moins le temps de
trente ans c'est sûr qu'on apprend
quarante ans sont les plus intéressés
par le bénévolat et puis 1 6% avant 60
ans l'âge du président
les associations marocaines 50% plus de
45 ans la répartition des bénévoles en
fonction des situations professionnelles
par les actrices et les fonctionnaires
assurément les enseignants et puis 3 %
des étudiants alors les motivations des
bénévoles marocains selon le but et
c'est l'implication citoyenne de
recherche besoin d'une reconnaissance à
recherche de sens et de réalisation
personnelle
l'acquisition de savoirs et
d'expériences la recherche de contacts
et de relations humaines basées sur
facilité partager la défense de mahler
est une souci de rendre au maroc sa
région
la dette morale le constat est
affligeant engagement à faire et puis au
fond des états unis j'ai regroupé à ce
moment
pas de grandes causes la première c'est
la frustration face au désengagement de
l'état social de discréditer partis
politiques cette frustration va être
passée des violences guerrero tant
qu'ils restent passifs le monde
associatif au sénat pas de projet
stratégique face à un détail aux partis
politiques ce qui fait de ce qui devait
être une coopération se transforme une
instrumentalisation des partis
politiques dans l'associatif à des vols
politique troisième coussin c'est
l'inversion de la pyramide des âges dire
les jeunes souris des lancers marocaine
par contre dans les partis politiques
des associations mais se paie comme une
horrible
et puis quatrième quand on sait que les
mouvements sociaux qui ont une base
sociale qui sont sur le terrain qui fait
beaucoup d'accent citoyens
ne gagnez pas coût d'adhésion chez des
jeunes marocains parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte que ces mouvements-là horaires ne
sont pas comme vous savez le social
n'est qu'une et qu'une excuse pour
conquérir le pot c'est comme ça qu'est
né demande l'initiative vers hysacam qui
est là pour encourager la culture du
bénévolat
pourquoi encourager le bénévolat d'abord
parce que ça a des retombées économiques
ça crée des richesses dont la lutte opl
le bénévole c'est une ressource
renouvelable non délocalisables peu
coûteuse et en plus un producteur de
services bénévoles a aussi à des
retombées sociales ça se terminerait
solidarité la cohésion entre les classes
sociales visaient aussi des retombées
politiques
ce que ça va donner des maux
d'humanisation progresser la démocratie
c'est ma les urnes
c'est pas juste des boilles qu'elles
soient transparents pour qu'on puisse
compter les votes mais c'est album
engagements nos citoyens dans les airs
classiques donc la lutte pour la démo
ne peut pas se fier uniquement dans les
institutions elle doit d'abord commencer
par la tête des sites web et puis le
bénévolat l'espace de dix réalisations
la démocratie parce qu'il permet de
développer la responsabilité de chacun
vis-à-vis de sa communauté
dernier de générer la participation
citoyenne et il offre un espace
d'expression de créativité de tous les
citoyens
c'est donc un indicateur de démocratie
participative qui révèle en quelque
sorte
est ce qu'une société civile et dinac et
comment vous y arrivez cette femme ait
un portail web qui va réaliser de
l'assemblée et fait réfléchir sur les
questions sociales la mairie
cette plateforme nouvelle qui va fédérer
et encourager les actions citoyennes
sans forcément adhérer à une association
qu'il existe il suffit de prendre une
photo
les actions citoyennes mettre le logo de
la campagne dessus le blosne et sur le
site une fois qu'il y ait des manies
départ administrateurs
on n'a pas de surprise
elle se retrouve catalogué dans
l'effectif par total donc lui aussi sur
un répertoire des actions à l'agora go
et un agenda du projet on développera
par là dessus on voit pas une obligation
pour smartphones permettra justement le
blood beaucoup plus simple sur le site
avec les possibilités d'organisation
englobe en région et d'intérieur
association qui elle partageait notre
action sur le banc
et puis une fois par an on aura les
jeunes amoureux at on va récompenser les
meilleures idées catégorie mâles de 5
semble un peu angoissant
on a pour l'instant six catégories ou
l'italie mais que dans l'immédiat j'ai
zappé notre fameux sac à main levée
douaniers certains cas des forces en vue
c'est un homme c'est à dégommer glisse
j'ai assisté à l'épaule et personnes
âgées les apprenants à l'éval canon
avait milité la défense de
l'environnement des animaux et du
consommateur du citoyen qu'elle maniait
sensibiliser éduquer informer exprimés 1
après jour sa levée et autonomiser les
femmes
savard groupe emploie les activités
revenu les projets d'intégration de
réhabilitation qu'un petit rôle au
baseball et défis dépassent les
handicaps manatee watrin bord du canal
qui anime ce qui concerne les nonistes
parce que pour pouvoir prendre soin des
autres
d'abord en soin de son fait tout ce qui
concerne les voyages aucune possibilité
aussi sur le c'est de faire une
recherche par nom pour voir s'il ya une
action dans sa lle de week-end prochain
pendant la période de 30 ans plongé
paris et donc grâce à ça on n'est pas
justement nous élire à ma frustration
d'instrumentalisation le monopole des
dinosaures des croquis vié et on n'est
pas dans les nouveaux ce qu'ont gagné et
participer à c'est le partage d'émotions
c'est pas facile de prendre des photos
et combler un scénario action web sur
mac beaux sentiments gratifiant de
participer un peu plus le combat
rechercher des solutions pragmatiques et
médias y était avoir un impact sur la
société
et puis la visibilité médiatique donc en
fait c'est plus un progrès c'est un état
d'esprit dans le sens que nissan 1
je suis responsable du développement de
mon pays et je n 1 je m'engage les
perspectives d'avenir parce que avoir
des bénévoles c'est bien uniforme il
faut pousser l'europe
premièrement c'est le regroupement des
bénévoles dans un cadre élégant
comprendre que les actions individuelles
des femmes et que un cadre légal rêvait
de faire de plus grandes choses
deuxième point éviter l'enfermement dans
le berry tarifs qui ne fait en fait de
remplacer les rames
troisième point d'opter pour des projets
durables et la grosse problématique
associations ces cinq hommes rendre les
personnes aidées les acteurs de
changement
la firme sedo de l'associatif pour
multiplier le daddy souvenir j'aime bien
cette délicieuse n'y fait c'est donc
multiplié par 10 e et puis dernier
vouloir promouvoir l'association de
m'éloigner de défendre chaque projet des
critiques mais alors qu'on a quand on en
a parlé un beau tour de nolan
principales critiques mme vallès et
tessin c'était que si moi je fais une
bonne action si je fais une action
citoyenne je le fais soit pour moi ou
alors je le fais c'est innover c'est un
élément qui ne médiatisé ça et de
prendre une photo pour la même chez pas
si je la réponse d'ailleurs deux volets
premier volet c'est que les mots grèce
d'exemples sont vraiment pas et puis
sont médiatisés par et les gens qui font
débat les actions de leçon
il est temps justement de médiatiser les
bonnes choses contre les mauvaises de ce
deuxième volet note le lien entre saddam
et religieux la petite histoire on
m'avait raconté il faut un compagnon du
brevet qui s'est élevé le soir pour
trier à la mosquée pour faire prier
menés ils étaient concentrés et vers le
moment il ya un autre compagnie à
rentrer et qui l'a vu briller à mener
ça lui a fait plaisir de voir du gâteau
tu l'as vu en train de prier le sont ils
allés voir le nouveau valent pour ce
pour ce bal et le plaisir que j'ai
encore une récompense aux indigènes les
régionales alors qu'en fait j'ai senti
que j'étais fait pour qu'on a aucun
hélas le trophée celui des lacs à raser
les cheveux brillants pour un
gentilhomme la récompense pour s'être
levé de son meurtrier
et c'est la règle on pense pourra ouvrir
la religion et inviter les gens à paris
si vous avez des idées et des
suggestions souvenez faire partie de la
campagne bannissement de prendre une
photo est apparue aux yeux le designer
développeurs de semaine
briand gignac dépendance en contact avec
nos pour l'instant les traces de projets
j'aimerais concours merci ce qu'on
aurait pu faire le déplacement
les membres se sont mitraillés point de
soyaux le samedi et une semaine